en novembre la balance commerciale a
encore été déficitaire de 3 milliards de
francs après la mort les quatorze
passagers du car de lyon le chauffeur
est inculpé un village venaient ces
ruines au guatemala c'est le dossier de
ce journal mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
comme vous sans doute j'aurais souhaité
n'avoir à vous parler ce soir que
d'événements souriant cette soirée de
noël qui est pour tous chrétiens ou non
chrétiens une fête une fête de famille
une fête des enfants nous y reviendrons
rassurez vous dans ce journal
mais l'actualité nous commande même si
elle est tragique et aujourd'hui elle a
été trahie elle a été dominée par
l'assassinât de jean de braye ancien
député républicain indépendant de leur
descendant d'une illustre famille sans
qu'on sache encore s'il s'agit d'un
meurtre politique il n'y a pas eu depuis
32 ans
d'assassinât de parlementaires ou
d'hommes politiques en france
le dernier homme politique assassine
était louis georges mandel a battu en
juillet 44 par des miliciens
jean de braye a été tué un peu avant 10
heures en sortant d'un immeuble du xviie
arrondissement à paris
son meurtrier un jeune homme d'une
vingtaine d'années qui a tiré sur lui
trois balles à bout portant une petite
rue proche des boulevards des maréchaux
dans le xviie arrondissement
il était un peu plus de 9h15 ce matin
les habitants du numéro 2 les voisins
entendent des coups de feu monsieur jean
de braye atteint d'une balle de 9 mm en
pleine tête s'écroule sur le trottoir il
va mourir quelques instants plus tard
je le connaissais pas ille-sur-tet de
cet immeuble dans le fond je ne pense
pas moi j'ai l'impression qui passe est
grave ça s'est passé comment qu'est ce
que vous avez entendu c'est à dire que
moi j'étais parti à mon courrier boue à
perte et alice quand je suis sorti de
chez man à la maison neuve
j'ai entendu des coups de feu quand je
suis arrivé au point j'ai vu le monsieur
tomber les gens qui se sont regroupés
qui tue alors je me suis précipité je
dis qu'est ce qui s'est passé personne
n'a répondu qui peut l'avoir tué il y à
bien un groupuscule d'extrême droite ce
club charles martel qui a revendiqué le
crime après coup mais près de quinze ans
après les accords d'evian auquel avait
participé monsieur de breuil on ne sait
trop ce qu'il faut croire
reste les témoins entendus par la police
ils sont peu nombreux et imprécis
quelqu'un a vu s'enfuir en courant juste
après les coups de feu un jeune homme
d'une vingtaine d'années il semble aussi
que monsieur de breuil est échangé
quelques mots avec son meurtrier
juste avant d'être abattu pour retrouver
l'assassin s'est peu d'un 10 le député
de l'eure n'avait dans le quartier ni
son domicile ni son bureau pourtant il
venait assez fréquemment et plusieurs
habitants de la rue connaissait sa
voiture au macaron parlementaire gare et
100 mètres plus loin et c'est peut-être
dans ce petit secteur de la rue des
dardanelles et par les dernières
personnes à y avoir rencontré monsieur
de brevets que la police pour en savoir
plus long sur ce meurtre qui paraît
d'abord inexplicable même si on peut lui
supposée des raisons politiques
oui jean de braye était un homme
politique extrêmement connue en
particulier depuis que secrétaire d'état
au sahara et aux dom tom il avait
activement participé aux accords d'evian
et il faut sans doute rapprocher de
cette ancienne fonction et de l'amitié
de jean de braye pour le monde arabe ce
coup de téléphone d'un mouvement
politique qui s'intitule donc le club
charles martel à l' agence france presse
et qui revendique l'attentât je cite ce
coup de téléphone
les forces vives de notre patrie indiqué
la wallonie glutron de plus en plus
contre l'invasion de ce tiers monde
inassimilable auprès de laquelle
l'invasion allemande était une plaisante
cet appel téléphonique est versée au
dossier mais les enquêteurs refusent de
le commenter depuis les accords d'evian
jean de braye avait occupé plusieurs
postes ministériels notamment sous les
gouvernements de bray et pompidou
il s'agirait et de siéger pardon depuis
très longtemps à l'assemblée où il
représentait la première circonscription
de l'eure c'est à dire evreux
c'est orateurs à la tribune de
l'assemblée était issu d'une famille
très illustre jean de braye comptait en
effet parmi ses aïeux trois maréchaux
quatre académiciens et imprimerie de la
littérature n'était pas absente de son
ascendance puisqu'il était aussi
l'arrière petit fils de madame de staël
mais après avoir été douze ans
conseiller d'état c'est à la politique
que jean de braye avait consacré cells
élu pour la première fois en 58 députés
indépendants de leurs il devient
secrétaire d'état au département
d'outre-mer en 61 et c'est à ce titre
qu'il négocie à evian 62 vous le voyez
ici entre messieurs joxe et buron
négocié les accords qui devait aboutir à
l'indépendance de l'algérie
il fut d'ailleurs un des co signataire
de ce heiva contre l'algérie où il
devait se rendre souvent par la suite
lorsqu'il devint ce sont trois
secrétaires d'état aux affaires
algériennes puis aux affaires étrangères
il devait notamment signer les premiers
d'accord entre la france et le nouveau
gouvernement algérien il redevient
simple député
en 67 après cette carrière ministérielle
chargée et il devait constamment être
réélu ensuite sous l'étiquette des
républicains indépendants et en 74
il soutint la candidature de monsieur
giscard d'estaing à la présidence de la
république depuis deux ans il y avait
pris quelques distances avec les
hérissons l'avait même remarqué au
rassemblement du rpr à la porte de
versailles
depuis la guerre il était aussi maire de
broglie ce petit village de l'eure
dominé par le château de ses ancêtres
la population a appris avec stupeur et
ensuite avec beaucoup de grandes peines
le décès de monsieur de breuil son maire
qui était très aimé ici et pour laquelle
pour laquelle comme une issue il était
très dévoué et la population a
immédiatement ressenti cette disparition
que beaucoup de peine
noël avant d'en venir au père noël il
faut tout de même dire et savoir que
noël n'aura pas le même goût pour tout
le monde du liban ou en dépit de
quelques sapins de quelques guirlandes
on n'y croit pas encore à l'irlande où
l'armée anglaise essaiera qu'il n'y ait
pas trop de sens s'est tenue encore
entre catholiques et protestants des
minorités opprimées aux prisons
totalitaire de la misère du tiers-monde
à la misère à la solitude la maladie
tout court noël comme tous les noël
n'aura pas pour tout le monde
le même bout c'est évident il faut je
crois y penser avant de songer est tout
de même à la joie à la joie des enfants
à la fête des familles aux mille et une
histoires que je pourrais vous raconter
sur ces noël joyeux du bout du monde où
c'est noël conte de fées comme ce maçon
malades à qui ses amis ont construit une
maison pendant qu'ils étaient à
l'hôpital
noël c'est noël et ce soir il est un peu
normal de laisser la parole aux enfants
un hélicotère paris je voudrais bien qu
ayant un petit chien la moindre petit
frère parce que vraiment je m'ennuie
tout ça chez moi elle et nous quittera
le palois et la musique à ce bon et puis
il reste que sont les autres dames âgées
alors qu'est ce que c'est le père noël
pour toi t'aurais à grande question
visez interne aux ailes et oui la [ __ ]
il habite dans dans les nuages quand il
descend chez toi les uns par la fenêtre
c'est pas monsieur père noël d'après
c'est le père noël non non pas du tout
parce que moi comme je l'avais lucernois
c'était pas un fraternel parce que
j'avais bien fait prêt oui mais vrai
père noël il existe dans les murs et
comment il a vu là une robe rouge
et puis pour faire la barbe c'est pas de
la frime art parce que c'est des coquins
ne croyez pas ne croyez jamais ce qu'ils
vous disent que le père noël n'existe
pas dans leur coeur et aussi dans leur
tête il ya sûrement du glo du noir 8 du
froid et plein de ces choses au goût
acide il existe le père noël la preuve
d'abord c'est qu'on a retrouvé le
village où il est né en turquie il ya
bien longtemps d'ailleurs louis douce et
vous le montrera demain 13h la preuve
c'est que sa vie qu'on appelle légende
se retrouvent inscrits dans toutes les
religions comme le déluge zanon ou sous
un autre la preuve qu'il existe le père
noël c'est bien sûr qu'on s'en sert
qu'on limite qu'on le faire croire
qu'ils aient dans les grands magasins
en réalité tous les gens sérieux c'est à
dire les enfants savent que c'est faux
père noël sont des idées de grands pays
des bêtes
d'ailleurs la preuve qu'il existe le
père noël c'est qu'ils se trompent
parfois ils métro dans une cheminée et
pas assez dans l'autre ou qu'ils
oublient par exemple la petite mona qui
réclamait ce matin son grand père devant
l'ambassade de bulgarie dont la porte la
frontière sont fermés
la preuve tenez un sondage récent de la
revue enfant magazine fait français sur
dix racontent à leurs enfants la barbe
blanche et le manteau rouge
sept français sur dix ne peuvent pas se
tromper ils votent leur loi élisent leur
chef avec bien moins de majorité la
preuve qu'il existe le père noël c'est
que plus on veut lui ressembler plus on
y croit essayer comme lui d'ouvrir la
porte à la dame âgée dans les enfants
sont partis essayez par exemple
de dire bonjour à l' homme au teint
sombre qui balaye essayé essayé de faire
plus même cela ne regarde que vous et
bien vous allez voir vous allez y croire
au père noël
monsieur gaston bonnet le ministre
l'agriculture ne mâche pas ses mots à
propos de certains producteurs de vin de
20 de mauvaise qualité que le ministre
je le cite assimile à une affreuse bibi
et quand je dis que monsieur bonnet ne
mâche pas ses mots vous allez le
constater je suis en dessous de la
vérité le dossier vitivinicole européen
est difficile à régler on le sait
visiblement christian bonnet ne supporte
pas que dans certains milieux on
continue à encourager les producteurs de
mauvais vin la bibine dans les quatre
départements du languedoc roussillon
cent mille exploitations réparties sur
quatre cent mille hectares produisent en
moyenne 30 millions d'hectolitres de vin
par an
sur ces 400 mille hectares 10% environ
produisent chaque année des quantités de
vin par trop considérable donc de
médiocre qualité et si monsieur bonef
bien continuer d'aider les producteurs
qui joue la carte de la qualité
il est très clair avec les autres et
disparaît je ne mettais plus violents
jeudi peuvent crever
selon ce ne sont pas les autres
les viticulteurs et jeudi qui font une
affreuse bibine et à raison de 200
hectolitres par hectare ce qu est un
rendement colossales ces viticulteurs
ces dernières années ont pesé sur le
marché des vins d'une façon extrêmement
fâcheuse qu'il n'est plus question pour
les pta de s'intéresser aux productions
massives qui contribue à donner une
mauvaise réputation aux vins du midi
dans leur ensemble alors qu'ils ne la
mérite pas et qui amène qui ont amené
dans le passé la france et la communauté
à aider des gens qui n'en n'avait nul
besoin et qui aurait dû au contraire
être pénalisées cet avis les
viticulteurs du midi ne le partage pas
bien sûr pour eux il s'agit d'une
manoeuvre
cette humeur que monsieur gougnan
manifeste
et semble marquer la gêne quand les
pouvoirs publics lorsqu'ils abordent la
question viticole parties n'ont pas de
politique viticole et qu'ils essaient de
tromper l'opinion à travers infos office
et une fausse interprofessions dès lors
la patience échappe
le dossier n'est pas valable et on se
laisse entraîner à des paroles de cet
ordre le commerce extérieur ils se
portent un tout petit peu de moi mal
tout de même ce mois ci le déficit en
chiffres bruts s'est sensiblement
aggravée certes mais en chiffres
corrigés
c'est à dire ce chiffre qui tient compte
des variations saisonnières le déficit
de la balance commerciale française
régresse légèrement 3878 millions de
francs au lieu de 4000 712 millions le
mois dernier cela dit le redressement
nos exportations reste l'un des
objectifs prioritaires du gouvernement
et la tâche essentielle d'andré rossi le
ministre du commerce extérieur comme ses
prédécesseurs
monsieur rossi s'est transformé en
véritable voyageur de commerce de la
france aux jeux olympiques du commerce
extérieur la france rate de peu la
médaille de bronze
elle est le quatrième exportateur
mondial juste derrière le japon après
les états unis et l'allemagne
en l'espace de quinze ans nos ventes à
l'étranger ont progressé rapidement et
nous avons diversifié nos clients les i
machines outils sur deux achetée par une
usine française vient toujours de
l'étranger nous achetons trop et nous ne
vendons pas encore suffisamment cette
année le déficit de la balance
commerciale va très certainement
dépasser 20 milliards
parmi les causes de ce déficit il y à la
reprise de l'activité à la fin de l'an
passé qui a entraîné un accroissement de
nos achats d'équipements à l'étranger il
y à la sécheresse qui a rendu les
récoltes moins abondantes et bien sûr
réduit nos exportations agricoles
la baisse du franc - 18 % par rapport
aux deux marques depuis le début de
l'année rend nos achats plus cher enfin
la facture pétrolière va dépasser 50
milliards cette année contre 14 en 1973
il faut ajouter celle des matières
premières quand 75 sur 223 milliards
d'importations qu'il y avait entre les
la facture pétrolière et des matières
premières
100 milliards de dépenses obligées pour
rétablir l'équilibré de la balance
commerciale il faut jouer sur ces deux
plateaux d'une part faire des économies
à l'achat de l'autre trouver de nouveaux
marchés de nouvelles entreprises
notamment petites et moyennes qui
accepte l aventure de l'exportation
m'exporter n'est pas seulement un
impératif pour notre commerce extérieur
un salarié sur quatre dans l'industrie
doit son emploi des ventes à l'étranger
le tiers de la production des usines
françaises franchi nos frontières
mais ce sont surtout les grandes
entreprises qui exportent 1400
entreprises assurent 80% des
exportations
les petites se partagent le reste des
opérations comme les nouveaux
exportateurs doivent inciter les moyens
entreprises à sortir de l'hexagone
il s'agit d'expliquer aux candidats
exportateurs les possibilités qu'offre
l'étranger et les aides dont ils peuvent
disposer ces caisses qui part pour
ouagadougou athènes encore des produits
made in france
les après avoir cherché ou exporter et
qui peut exporter un problème se pose
quoi exporter les pays dans lesquels
l'exportons sont tous par définition des
pays en voie d'industrialisation
puisqu'ils nous achète des ensembles
industriels et que donc progressivement
il fait ils fabriquent eux-mêmes des
équipements il s'équipe eux mêmes en
bureau d'étude et il est évident qu'ils
commencent par les choses les moins
difficiles
donc notre place sur le marché ont
valeur relative portent de plus en plus
sur des choses très élaboré
quand un pays achète puisqu'il le vent
il vit au dessus de ses moyens c'est
pourquoi le déficit extérieur de la
france des pas tolérable longtemps le
vrai pro à la maintenance est
d'augmenter nos exportations de biens de
consommation et tout ceci évidemment et
fonction aussi de la réappréciation du
franc c'est à dire de la fin de la
relation actuelle mais on peut
considérer qu'en 60 17 devrions
retrouver à ce moment là une situation
améliorée par rapport annuel semestre
ça ne sera pourtant pas encore l'
équilibre lui même mais une situation
suffisamment améliorée pour que l'on
puisse dans ce domaine considéré que le
plan pourra donc être appliquée comme il
a été pré trouver de nouveaux clients
vendre davantage de produits ne sera pas
suffisant si la france ne renforce pas
ces structures de pays exportateurs mais
surtout si elle ne parvient pas à rendre
offrant une position de monnaie forte
c'est pourquoi la lutte contre
l'inflation et le redressement du
commerce extérieur sont étroitement liés
santiago carillo le secrétaire-général
du parti communiste espagnol arrêté le
22 décembre dernier a été inculpé cet
après-midi ainsi que sept de ses amis
inculpé de participation à une
association illicite en qualité de
dirigeant
ils encourent tous une peine de six ans
de prison les avocats feront appel
demain et demanderont la liberté
provisoire au moins pour les fêtes de
noël plusieurs réactions en france après
cette décision d'abord un télégramme de
françois mitterrand au premier ministre
espagnol
souhaitant que cesse ce toute
discrimination politique et s'élevant
contre l'arrestation de santiago carillo
par ailleurs jean canapa membre du
bureau politique du parti communiste
français a annoncé qu'une manifestation
serait organisée lundi par le pc devant
l'ambassade d'espagne un parc à
château-thierry dans l'aisne un hold up
dans un supermarché hier soir a très mal
fini
quatre malfaiteurs masqués armés après
avoir raflé le contenu du coffre c'est à
dire environ 15000 france se sont enfuis
avec une otage une jeune fille qui a été
retrouvé vers 1h du matin tout près de
paris mais trois policiers alertés par
un client et qui avait tenté
d'intercepter les malfaiteurs ont été
pris sous le feu du pistolet mitrailleur
de l'un d'entre eux un inspecteur de
police de 25 ans atteint de plusieurs
balles est mort à l'hôpital
le jeune chauffeur du car tomber dans le
rhône mardi soir en raison d'un épais
brouillard a été inculpé aujourd'hui par
le juge d'instruction dans le cadre de
l' enquête et de la recherche des
responsabilités
le chauffeur a été laissé en liberté les
obsèques des victimes ont eu lieu ce
matin à vénissieux dans la banlieue de
lyon où résidait la plupart des familles
des 14 victimes 14 cercueil recouvert
d'un drap blanc aligné dans l'église des
minguettes à vénissieux
la cérémonie des obsèques des victimes
13 enfants dont le plus jeune avait à
peine six ans et une femme qui les
accompagnait s'est déroulée devant une
foule silencieuse les parents les amis
ont écouté les différentes interventions
des célébrants catholique protestant et
musulman après les condoléances aux
familles les cercueils ont été placés
dans les fourgons mortuaires de très
nombreuses gerbes de fleurs blanches
couvrait les véhicules il faut
maintenant dégager les responsabilités
de cet accident comment le car est il
tombé dans le rhône trois inculpations
ont été notés notifié à l'encontre de
jean noël maury le chauffeur du car
homicide involontaire blessures
involontaires et défaut de maîtrise d'un
véhicule
ce sont des inculpations cela ne veut
pas dire que le chauffeur est
responsable par ailleurs les fédérations
cgt cfdt des transports ont annoncé leur
intention de se porter partie civile
afin sans doute d'avoir accès au dossier
de l'anc est en cours enfin nouvelle
expertise du caire a été faite cet après
midi temps que les hommes auront faim
c'est le titre d'une émission des
missions que vous verrez mercredi
prochain sur antenne 2 un magazine de
l'actualité de roger pic sur les
innombrables problèmes de la faim dans
le monde et de la solde de la solidarité
pardon internationale et je crois qu'en
cette soirée de noël il n'est peut-être
pas inutile de s'arrêter déjà un instant
sur un exemple de détresse mais aussi de
solidarité vous souvenez peut-être du
tremblement de terre en février 76 au
guatemala dans le mond terre qui avait
fait 25 morts et soixante quinze mille
blessés
grâce à l'unicef en particulier aussi à
d'autres on a pu apporter à ces hommes
de l'amérique latine un peu
de réconfort et de secours une équipe
d'antenne 2 est allé dans un petit
village de subway témala meurtri pour
voir et pour raconter shikin sinaï un
village du guatemala qui a été
entièrement détruits lors du tremblement
de terre dans ce village en quelques
secondes
onze morts 3 130 blessés la survie de
ces indiens qui sont d'origine maya est
avant tout lié au problème de l'eau
l'installation de pompes est vital dans
ces villages car l'eau source de vie
peut être génératrice de bien des
maladies lorsqu'elle est pollué une
jeune française mireille aide depuis le
mois de février
les 350 indien de chicken sinaï à
survivre faisons ce puits nous essayons
d'aller le plus profond possible pour
capter une eau pure envoyez-le à l'eau
était encore de dégoûtante et d'avoir
les saletés qui tombe n'ayant plus la
bouée ya on n'a pas trouvé le filon
clair encore et alors on va vider le
puits est esclave est de 4 m de plus il
y aura cette eau pour tout le village
aura ses deux potes au village on a
prévu une consommation de 600 litres par
heure raison de huit heures par jour
finalement assez peu ça ne puisera pas
la source
selon la coutume indienne toutes les
décisions sont prises en communauté les
hommes du village se réunissent
quotidiennement pour discuter des
problèmes de nutrition de santé
d'hygiène et de scolarisation des
enfants dans ces villages du guatemala
il reste encore beaucoup à faire et
avant le tremblement de terre les
indigènes vivaient déjà dans des
conditions difficiles
n'ayant comme seul nourriture que le
maïs et les reliques et c'est là
qu'interviennent les organisations
internationales telles que l'unicef qui
donne aux paysans les moyens d'améliorer
leurs conditions de vie à eux de les
mettre en application
en accord avec le chef du village vous
êtes le chef du village et j'aimerais
savoir comment vous vous êtes organisé
après le tremblement de terre au moment
du trentenaire qu'on nous avons vu
toutes nos maisons détruites
on s'est réunis et on s'est organisé
pour les doublés de l'année mais aussi
pour essayer de sauver le bois des
charpentes ya tout ce qui pouvait être
sauvé
puis on s'est organisé aussi pour les
travaux agricoles pour récupérer le
maillot
le jour du 4 février aucune des maisons
de check in china il restait de lire
grâce au matériel de l'unicef et aux
dons privés
chacun va reconstruire sa maison vingt
mille briques viennent d'être livrés
nous étions le premier secours arrivés
en quelque sorte les maisons étaient en
ruines les blessés étaient encore dans
les ruines et il avait enterré leurs
morts
combien de morts officiellement deux
morts recensés devant la mairie en fait
11 morts d'après ce que nous avons pu
faire aux questions dont les gens savoir
plus région mirail se bat depuis
plusieurs mois pour faire livrer le
matériel nécessaire à la reconstruction
et à discuter de vie sert
d'intermédiaire entre les indigènes
le gouvernement et les fournisseurs et
le gouvernement comment s'étaient
comportés face aux problèmes de ces
villages bien
il ad'abord parer au plus pressé c'est à
dire aux problèmes sanitaires au plus
pressé c'est à dire oh toi il avait un
pari de 100 jours à tenir parce que 100
jours après le tremblement de terre
c'était la date prévue plus ou moins des
pluies et il avait fait le pari que
chaque famille aurait un soin pari tenu
et il a aidé aussi les gens à dos départ
les gens avaient toute leur récolte
soûles et sous les décombres il les a
donc aidé à retrouver un petit peu de
quoi manger des choses comme ça c'est le
gouvernement guatémaltèque a aidé les
indiens après le tremblement de terre il
en fut autrement gaz riche propriétaire
des plantations et même des industriels
la place conséquente elle n'a pas été
tellement concernés car ils sont
propriétaires de deux grandes
plantations sur la côte qui n'ont pas
été douchés en général les maisons bien
construite à caboter malades ville n'ont
pas souffert le les installations
industrielles n'ont pas souffert non
plus quelque chose sont sentis concernés
car ils avaient des ouvriers vivent dans
des villages détruits et ils ont dû
céder un peu au paternalisme mais dans
l'ensemble ils se sont pas sentis
concernés n'ont pas été très actif par
lino quant à lui s'est porté volontaire
pour apprendre quelques bases de
médecine il a suivi un stage de trois
mois organisée par les équipes de lui
f cette formation lui permet de
pratiquer quelques soins d'urgence de
détecter et de diriger vers l'hôpital
les cas les plus critiques
telle est la vie des indigènes des hauts
plateaux du guatemala avant pendant et
depuis ce tremblement de terre chaque
effort chaque acte peuvent être pour
l'instant considérés comme insuffisants
mais accumulé ces efforts fournis par
les organisations internationales et par
nous tous feront peut-être qu'un jour
les enfants de cetin sinaï pourront
avoir une espérance de vie de plus de 45
ans parce qu'ils seront mieux nourris
mieux soigner mieux éduqués
les paul lefeuvre avait raison le père
noël existe puisque j'apprends à
l'instant qu'un fabuleux cadeau de noël
a été offert aujourd'hui n'ont eu guère
très exactement sur le champ de courses
de cagnes-sur-mer 665 mille francs je
crois que c'est le plus gros pari jamais
gagné à un unique gagnant pour une mise
initiale de 5 francs le parieur et qui
préfère garder l'anonymat et on le
comprend avait tenté une mise de 5
francs donc sur un parti paris
particulier qui s'appelle le pari trio a
kind il y avait encore beaucoup de
brouillard aujourd'hui et comme vous
pouvez le constater j'y reviendrai dans
un instant car cela va continuer le
brouillard a déjà beaucoup tué en ces
veilles de fêtes carambolage monstre sur
l'autoroute du soleil
voiture contre carreaux voiture contre
voiture en dépassement suicidaire le
bilan est déjà très lourd donc je ne
saurais que vous conseiller beaucoup de
prudence la visibilité et vous l'avez
vue sur ces images dans certaines
régions est extrêmement mauvaise en
particulier dans l'est de la france la
vallée du rhône et le nord est sont
souvent givrants ces brouillards ce qui
accentue les risques et les dangers
les températures sont en baisse un peu
partout demain les gelées matinales
s'accentueront il fera très froid dans
l'est de la france nous en venons donc à
la météo et le temps restera extrêmement
brumeux avec des brouillards givrants je
le répète par endroits et le soir
quelques chutes de neige sur les régions
du nord et de l'est les régions du midi
seront toutefois encore à l'écart de ce
refroidissement mais les nuages ils
seront cependant très abondant quelques
pluies aussi et de la neige en montagne
toujours
je vous indique tout de suite qu'il fera
encore un peu plus froid dimanche avec
d'abondantes chutes de neige sur la
moitié nord du pays et en montagne
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal avec
toute la rédaction antenne 2 je vous
souhaite un très joyeux noël de très
belles fêtes et un peu de joie si vous
êtes seul en vous proposant par exemple
de rester avec nous ce soir sur antenne
2 pour une soirée spéciale qui va
commencer par les brigades du tigre et
qui se poursuivra par une longue veillée
de noël préparé pour vous par toute
l'équipe de jaga bonsoir et tout de
suite le rappel des principaux titres de
l'actualité
jean de braye assassiné à paris
viticulture le gouvernement s'attaque à
la surproduction balance commerciale
légère réduction du déficit en novembre
le chauffeur du car de lyon est inculpé
pour 7 par an sur 10 le père noël doit
exister pas de journal ce soir 23h
21h30 la nuit de noël sur antenne 2
celle de graziella et virginie